wie fängt man so was ich war es eben
gerade in der uni von 9 bis 13 uhr
gerade auch beim supermarkt hergegangen
und habe mir noch eine hühnersuppe
geholt und nirgendwo und so weil ich
gerade so ein bisschen am kränkeln
begann dann aber auf jeden fall zu hause
an und habe dann im briefkasten gehabt
und sie auf einmal so ein paket abholen
schein obwohl ich mir eigentlich nichts
bestellt habe damit dabei hat erstmal
nicht viel gedacht hat dem paket
abholschein genommen mit meinem nachbarn
hingegangen ist paket abgeholt und hab
ich schon drauf gesehen dass das ein
studio 1 70 aufkleber dran war studio 71
ist es youtube netzwerk bei dem ich
gefahren bin also die managen quasi ein
bisschen main kanal und was kooperation
in fragen geht die sonne kommt gerade
raus ich hoffe dass jetzt nicht die
lichtverhältnisse oder so ein paar
sekunden später die sonne verschwindet
wieder
ich hasse herbst hat das paket dann auf
jeden fall einfach ausgepackt ohne das
jetzt irgendwie zu film weil ich dachte
es geht um irgendeinen stinknormales
paket aber ich nehme ich mal kurz mit in
die küche und zeigt euch was da drin war
so sieht das ganze paket hier aus also
stehen wir hinten ist übrigens auch der
einkauf von gerade also kein placement
oder sollte das ganze dann auf jeden
fall aufgerissen und guckt da rein und
sehe eine drohne ich meine kann es jeden
die drohne senden arrangiertes wenn die
renten und eben aus diesem grund rufen
jetzt mal zusammen mein manager bei
studio 71 an und fragen warum ich mit
rhone bekommen habe also versteht das
nicht falsch das ist ultra cool dass
sich eine drohne habe ich weißt du nicht
ganz genau warum
google habe ich einmal ein video ein
bisschen strukturierter und mit
verschiedenen shots und sohn will
jemanden anrufen geht einfach nicht dran
hubert ist es cool dass ich erreiche
weil ich habe mir ja rat nicht erreicht
und zwar habe ich gerade in meinem
postkasten guckt unterlag mit drohne von
euch dass ihr zu mir gehen sollte wofür
brauche ich eine drohne das ding wird
nur kaputt gehen ok jetzt gehört freunde
und zwar dass gerade eine studie 1 70m
einfach gesagt okay ich sollte
vielleicht jetzt nicht komplett
volldampf machen direkt beim ersten mal
natürlich machen wir direkt vollgas
herzebrock mit patrick und so irgendwo
zum park zu laufen und die einfach mal
zu testen für ein video von mir okay ich
ruft patrick alle bescheid
man hat etwas geht
ich habe irgendwie drohne zugeschickt
bekommen von studio 1 70 aus berlin und
ich wollen ihr zum parken bisschen test
und damit rumfliegen ist ein
youtube-video familie zu wort zu kommen
so freude wir sind jetzt hier im park
angekommen wie heißt du eigentlich haben
hier so eine serie von barren
ich bin jetzt verbunden mit der drohne
kann jetzt hinstellen und jetzt
ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt raus nehmen
ich habe die anleitung nicht gelesen ich
weiß nicht wie hoch fliegen kann
also das was wir gerade machen ist
glaube ich eigentlich illegal weil man
mit rauen license braucht aber wir sind
ja auch privaten gelände glaube ich ich
hatte die gerade auf 940 auf 260 gewehr
ohne möglichkeit auf der stelle
und jetzt das ding nach oben ich weiß
jetzt kann man gut durch das mal an was
da ist der dom herz oder hast was wie
geil ist das denn
kann mir jemand drehen da haben wir da
hinten im fernsehturm aber hier die
ganzen uni krems und so heilige kuh die
drohne ist besoffen bei ihr
leute wir haben nur noch 28 das heißt
ich will das ding jetzt mal ein bisschen
runter neuen akku 18 die hat eine follow
me funktion ob gott nähe doch nur 20
prozent
vielleicht verkaufen wollte
sehr gute drohne
ich werde gleich noch mal in meiner
wohnung das ding aufladen und dann noch
mal ein bisschen damit fliegen in meiner
wohnung also mal schauen was ich da noch
irgendwas kaputt mache oder so aber das
war auf jeden fall erstmal aufwärts aus
dem park okay vielleicht hab ich
vergessen als ich heute noch zwei
weitere termine hatte es ist gerade 18
uhr 7 und ich bin gerade rest meiner
wohnung wieder angekommen deswegen ist
es dementsprechend schon dunkel draußen
die belichtung ist nicht allzu gut ich
muss hier gerade mit meinen lampen und
so arbeiten aber was ich auf jeden fall
noch mal machen wollte war die drohne
hier in meiner wohnung fliegen
ich bin meinem freund etwas zitrone
schritt hey das trasse ist einfach ich
spiele weiter unter der drohne und die
macht immer noch wind gucke ich meine
haare an leute ich bin zwei meter unter
der drohne
diese einfach mal ab wo geflogen ich
weiß nicht ob man das rad auf kamera
gesehen hat aber ich wollte wirklich die
drohne gerade wieder runter holen auf
einmal steigt die irgendwo macht so ihr
eigenes ding
das ist wenn man andere youtuber würden
jetzt wahrscheinlich negativ compilation
machen aber
ok ich sehe das ganze jetzt mal durch
die drohne davon
nach vorne zu mir kommt er kommt
wirklich ankommt
ein stück nach oben
und wird die den ganzen strapazen
hopkins neue rohr ich krieg die ganze
zeit irgendwelche terrors das ergebnis
fiel aber etwas
unter die drohne league teil
da denkt jeder an dass man das nicht
machen sollte was ich die ganze zeit
mache
das ist eine pflanze bei mir in der
wohnung und die droge hat gerade das
blatt abrasiert und diese beiden blätter
die drohne hat die schutzvorrichtungen
verloren ein standfuß unten abgeknickt
da unten liegt eine schutzvorrichtung
und da hinten liegen auch noch zwei
verteilt der einzige sport den ich heute
hinkriegen sollte war dass sich unter
der drohne bin und sie unter der drohne
liege das hab ich hingekriegt wollte ich
dir danach wieder landen nur irgendwie
war dann dieser baum ihr all dem weg ich
guck mal ob ich die drohne irgendwie
hinkriege ob die doch funktioniert weil
haben mal wieder 7000 terrors die mir
angezeigt wurden an der stelle trotzdem
noch mal ein großes danke an studio 71
die mir einfach irgendein drohne hierzu
geschickt haben ich hab ich gesagt das
ist im sinne der spitze in den falschen
händen bei mir aber trotzdem freunde
wenn euch das video gefeiert last man
neigt am jetzt auf jeden fall mega spaß
gemacht danke auch an meine kollegen
serge und patrick mit denen ich da im
park war die mir dabei im film geholfen
haben wir hatten auch schon die idee und
luftballons zu holen und die luftballons
einfach an die drohne dran zu machen und
dann die luftballons bedingen dörfern
abzuschießen aber das sind glaube ich
einfach unsere kranken gehirne wieder
ein bisschen durchspielen wir sehen uns
im nächsten video
hier ist wieder der typische luca der am
ende eines umstrittenen videos noch mal
so ein bisschen real talk betreibt ich
denke dass sehr viele leute jetzt in den
kommentaren ankommen werden und zum
helden werden von wegen
gigalocal richtig teuer die drohne wie
kann es sein dass du damit so scheiße
umgeht ich zitiere weil sowas immer sehr
gern casey leistet
halt einfach so das ist sein hier das
ist science darf und er kann damit
machen was er will und er kann es auch
alles in die tonne setzen und es ist
einfach sein zeug und er kann damit
machen was er will und außerdem ist das
eine chance drohne ich habe hier jetzt
ja keinen menschen zerstört oder das
auto von jemandem sondern einfach nur so
eine drohne die mir zu gesendet wurde
deswegen wenden hier irgendwo ankommt
und was soll da ist dass du ihr eine
drohne zerstörst hey es ist meine ich
kann damit machen was ich will und sie
ist ja noch nicht komplett zerstört und
an der stelle auch die zweite sache die
ich noch eben sagen wollte und zwar die
drohne funktionieren ich bin damit
gerade noch mal kunst geflogen die es
ein bisschen so als wenn sie betrunken
wer habe sich fliegt zu mindestens noch
ich will nicht der zehntausendste
youtuber werden irgendwelche drogen
schutzmacht und meine stadt fliegt ich
dachte echt vorher so okay dass ein
krasser auflage ist voll schwierig zu
machen ist es nicht ich habe es direkt
nach zwei minuten ohne anleitung lesen
hingekriegt ich bin einfach nicht so ein
typ der so was macht so ich will ihnen
was verrücktes mit der drohne machen wie
beispielsweise irgendwie helium ballons
mit der drohne abschieds mit den
rotorblättern die zerstören oder
irgendwas verrücktes wenn ihr der ideen
habt schreibt es gerne meine kommentare
werden auf jeden fall bock darauf mit
der drohne irgendwas total verrücktes zu
machen
deswegen kauft euch aus um den
kommentaren lassen like aber nicht das
video gefallen hat und ihr mehr drohnen
videos haben wollte und siemens